I'm going to start out with Paul Krugman
and afterwards you know I hope that
Christopher Hitchens has cancelled but
we have a fabulous second act first act
actually James Reston jr. will show us
the frost/nixon interview tapes the
actual tapes and then later in the day
you can hear him talk about his
award-winning book Nixon okay please
turn off your telephones beepers iPhones
whatever you have that makes noise know
that this is being taped for c-span - I
hope you told your family you might be
on and you will be able to pull it up on
iTunes you a little as soon as we can
get them all loaded under Miami Dade
College you have to join iTunes U which
is a go to the iTunes site and load that
on your computer Mac or PC it does not
matter and then you go to miami-dade
College and it will be book fair I was
told we may be on the first page now but
we will be at the top then and then you
can enjoy all of the programs we videoed
throughout the book fair and you can see
them in the middle of the night and
early in the morning whenever you want
show your friends tell them what they
missed hope they'll be here next year
for our 25th anniversary
it is my pleasure to get the morning
started by introducing Charles Chapman
he is a friend of Miami Book Fair you
seen him for years and it was our
delight to ask him to introduce Paul
Krugman Thank You Barbara Paul Krugman
has enjoyed a remarkable career as an
economist and newspaper columnist as a
young man he won the John Bates Clark
Medal which is awarded to outstanding
economists under the age of 40 he also
Believe It or Not served in the Reagan
White House as a member of the Council
of Economic Advisors he gained national
prominence in 2001 when he began writing
op-eds twice a week for the New York
Times focusing on political economics he
aimed a gimlet eye at the Bush
administration's tax cuts and later
attempt to reform Social Security he
consistently exposed false and
misleading explanations offered by the
White House that had been accepted by
others in an all too accommodating news
media more recently he has expanded his
purview to the entire political scene
mr. Krugman in Vaes against the
conservative establishment and lays out
a liberal vision for the country in his
book the conscience of a liberal he also
teaches economics and international
affairs at Princeton University
ladies and gentlemen Paul Krugman
so
my apologies about the high-tech here
but I want to read you some quotes and
Jesus with you also I better explain
about that Council of Economic Advisors
thing I was on the staff not a member
and there was a group of technocrats who
were brought in at that point and the I
was the senior international economist
the senior domestic economist was guy
named summers Larry Summers don't know
what happened to him so anyway it was an
interesting time actually did partially
I think at some level and informed
conscience of a liberal because I did
get to see that administration close up
ok first a why conscience of a liberal
obviously I'm echoing the title of Barry
Goldwater's book there are some
differences among the factor I actually
wrote mine but the but the Goldwater
book although I obviously disagree with
where it was going it did mark the
beginning of a big turn in American
politics and the belief and hope of
conscience of a liberal is that were at
another great turn that were we're ready
for a big shift in direction for
reversing what I obviously regard as the
very bad direction we've been going for
several decades in this country before I
get to that the book is largely about
before it gets to prescription and where
we can go it a lot of is about how we
got here
and so a lot of it is history it goes
all the way back to the Gilded Age it's
largely about two themes and I want to
talk about those two themes for a while
here so one of the themes is the the
fall and rise of inequality in America
the which is a process really you need
to go back 70 years to get the whole
story the creation of middle-class
society and the the return to a highly
unequal Society so let me just tell you
first something that many people know
which is that the middle class Society
of the post-war years on a baby boomer
the society I grew up in did not evolve
gradually out of the the highly out of
the Gilded Age out of the highly
unequal Society of the late 19th century
it's not the case that gradually America
evolved a strong middle class it
happened very suddenly happened in
really between the late 1930s and the
mid 1940s and the economic historians
call it the great compression income
differences were compressed together and
it happened politically it was in fact
the New Deal of the Roosevelt
administration that created Social
Security unemployment insurance minimum
wage highly progressive taxation
pro-union
or these labor laws that safeguarded the
right of workers to organize and then
during World War two the way that that
wage and price controls were
administered had the effect of
equalizing incomes but remarkably that
change in the the narrowing of
inequality that took place during the
war lasted turns out that our notion
that impersonal market forces determine
what wages are is exaggerated that you
feel established a set of new norms
about how people ought to be paid it can
last for a very long time um that lasted
hasn't said for about thirty years after
World War Two a little bit more but then
beginning in the late 1970s we started
to pull apart and the at this point when
people talk about a second Gilded Age it
is not that's not hyperbole that's not a
metaphor by the numbers the inequality
of income today is as great as it was in
the 1920s just about exactly the same as
it was in the 1920 so we have gone fully
back to the kinds of inequality we had
before the great compression how did
that happen one of the arguments are
make in the book is that to a much
greater extent than people imagine it is
a question not of the invisible hands of
the marketplace not of Technology and
globalization but of changes in
institutions which are ultimately in
turn driven by politics now I can't in
this format do the whole thing but I can
tell you let me just give you a sample
so one of the things that clearly has
changed in America is the near collapse
of the union movement in the 1960s we
had about 30 percent of workers and
unions it's now 12 person
and in the private sector it's under 8%
so we have this great reduction in
unions and there's a lot of reasons a
lot of evidence that that a strong union
movement while there are a lot of things
you can say about it one effect it does
have definitely as is equalizing both
through the direct effect on Union wages
and through the effects that strong
union movement has on norms throughout
the society and of course everybody
knows that the reason that unions have
declined so much is well you know it's
just a changing economy technology
globalization except that the collapse
of the union movement is unique to the
United States other advanced countries
haven't seen anything like it so that if
we look at if we look at Canada which is
you know pretty faces the same
globalization the same technology it's
rather close to the United States and
even almost speaks the same language on
the in Canada 30% of workers are still
unionized so what happened and if you
look at the timing it turns out their
collapse of the union movement in the
United States mostly happened during the
1980s there was not a clear decline
until Ronald Reagan came to office and
then what happened well it's it's
combination of things that there were
symbolic things like the firing of the
air traffic controllers and a general
change towards essentially not
enforcement of the labor laws and the
widespread illegal firing of workers who
voted for unions the after I think about
the difference that makes you know why
is Walmart not unionized it's not that
it's inherently unsuitable on the
contrary it's a giant firm doesn't face
international competition why shouldn't
it have a union
well basically Walmart got big in a
period when the political environment
was entirely favorable to union busting
efforts and that's why America's largest
employer has no union where does this
political environment come from and
that's the second big story the fall and
rise of political polarization so we
have I talked about in the book a lot
about
movement conservatism which is not my
term it's actually the term that the
movement conservatives themselves use
there is you know yes Virginia there is
a vast right-wing conspiracy except it's
not hidden there's a clearly overlapping
interlocking set of institutions with
common purpose ranging all the way from
the Heritage Foundation to Fox News has
clearly defined common goals interchange
of personnel common funding sources it's
really extraordinary how many of these
institutions when you look in particular
at the seed money at who gave them money
to get going you find over and over
again
Richard Mellon Scaife Koch : course
Smith Richardson Bradley the same set of
foundations same set of essentially
wealthy families behind it all
I I've always thought that the I can't
for us was talking this afternoon the
you know the conspiracy theories the
George Soros was behind everything
he's behind even global warming that's
all as something a myth created by the
Soros conspiracy I've always thought
that you know there various reasons why
this is such a popular myth on the right
and but one of them I think is that the
idea that an evil billionaire is
coordinating everything behind the
scenes makes sense then because that is
the way things work in their world
how one of one of the goals of moving
conservatism what they are principally
at core they're different I'll talk in
the moment but why people vote for it
but the reason if you look at the move
at the institution's themselves what
they're fundamentally about is economics
and particular rolling back the the
forces that produce the great
compression so that a fundraising letter
from from the Heritage Foundation which
reminds people to connect the dots it
says today's policies are a product of
the Great Society of the 1960s which
grew out of the New Deal of the 1930s
which was an assault on founding
principles so you know New Deal Great
Society Social Security Medicare all of
that is bad we need to get rid of it
and my favorite sorry there's a small
dog living in my throat here as you'll
hear and yapping now and then the grover
norquist americans for tax action who
get quite significant figure in the
movement sent for piece of the the K
Street project to corral the lobbyists
into being Republican supporters but
also somebody said I have to track this
down that he's he's like a James Bond
villain who likes to explain his evil
plans to you in detail so we like to
quote Griffin Bergquist the quote
everybody knows is the one about wanting
to shrink the government to the size
where you can drown it in the bathtub
but the one I like is he was asked how
did where does he want us to go he said
he wanted us to get back to the way it
was before Teddy Roosevelt when the
socialists took over the income tax the
death tax regulation all that so it's a
really it's a it's essentially roll back
all of the liberal equalizing
institutions of the 20th century okay
that is not has never been a an election
winning platform most people you know
really like Social Security Medicare
when asked about it they generally don't
think that rich people are paying enough
taxes and so on it's not always effect
to run on those issues but it's
certainly people don't support that
program so how has this conservative
movement actually won so many elections
well the answer is by running other
other stuff so the chapter in constable
liberal titled weapons of mass
distraction couldn't help myself these
things include obviously particular in
recent years national security cultural
issues and in a way you in one way what
happened in 2004 was almost perfect as
an illustration of both what the
movement is about and about how it has
to achieve political success 2004 was a
mainly national security and personally
cultural election or as I like to say
Bush ran as the defender of the nation
against gay marry terrorists but then as
soon as the election was over he said on
our first priority is the privatization
of Social Security so was this you know
remarkable and a lot of this people who
voted for him or basically what that
wasn't what we thought we were voting
for um however in a different sense 2004
was unusual because national security
and cultural things have on the whole
and I did a lot of work here on reading
the political science research have had
been much less significant in driving
elections for the most part than people
think
2002 2004 were national security
elections but that was unusual mainly
what it's been about and this is
something I didn't expect I was gonna
come to when writing the book and it's
something that a lot of people find
unacceptable but it was about race if
you it's just overwhelming
let's tell you what what's overwhelming
in the numbers once you look at the fact
that southern whites switched parties
after the civil rights movement there's
very little else left to explain so for
example there have been endless
explanations of why white men have
stopped voting Democratic we know it's
about moral values it's about guns it's
about abortion it's about Democrats are
weak on national security the Democrats
of the Maumee party all of these things
to explain why white men have turned
away from the Democrats except it never
happened once you take this or gonna
switch into account in 1952 forty
percent of non southern white males
voted
mccr attic in 2004 39% of non southern
white males voted Democratic there is
nothing to explain once you take into
account the fact that southern whites
started voting Republican all of these
other things are just not a major factor
in the in the elections now as a
question was this a deliberate strategy
well we know that Richard Nixon said
let's pursue the southern strategy that
was deliberate on his part Ronald Reagan
there's nothing around Reagan has been
elevated to saintly status people get
very upset when you suggest that maybe
he was a bit of a cynical political
operator and so there's been there's
hysterical reaction to the suggestion
that when Ronald Reagan opened his 1980
campaign not with a speech on tax cuts
not with a speech on national security
but by going to Philadelphia Mississippi
where the three civil rights workers
have been murdered in 1964 and saying I
believed in local control of Education I
believe in states rights the people say
you know that yes you shouldn't have
said that but he really didn't mean
anything by it it was just it was not a
shout-out to southern whites was just an
innocent mistake and you have to say
look that does fit in character because
Reagan did have a tendency to make
innocent mistakes when he went on and on
about the welfare queen driving her
Cadillac and kept telling the story
years after it had in fact been debunked
it never happened a lot of people
thought that was a shout-out to you know
implicit racist rhetoric but it was just
an innocent mistake when he gave
speeches about how annoyed people must
be when they're buying groceries and
ahead of them in line is some strapping
young buck buying t-bone steaks oddly he
didn't he only used he gave that speech
about the groceries and the food stands
in a lot of places but he only used the
word strapping young buck when he's
talking to southern audiences but he
didn't actually mean that to be a
call-out to racism was just an innocent
mistake when he said that in 1980
that the Voting Rights Act of 1965 had
been humiliating to the south and that
he didn't mean to be saying that he
thought that blacks should have been
continued to be excluded from the polls
it was just an innocent mistake when he
intervened on behalf of Bob Jones
University which was trying to keep its
tax-exempt status he really didn't know
that the reason it was losing it was
because it banned interracial dating and
he certainly didn't mean to give any
signals there was just an innocent
mistake and when he opposed the making
Martin Luther King Day a national
holiday conceding only after the law
creating the holiday was passed by huge
veto proof bipartisan majorities he
really wasn't mean to send any single it
was it was just an innocent mistake okay
well you get the picture it's pretty
clear that this was a deliberate
strategy and as I say that the the
race-based shift in American voting
leaves I say inconceivable there's
almost nothing left to explain they all
the other things that you give about why
the New Deal coalition lost control of
the country and why the conservative
movement was so successful all of those
explanations are actually trying to
explain something that isn't there which
is the residual shift to the Republicans
other than that that's clearly related
to the backlash against the civil rights
movement so this is a happy book
and it's a happy book because I I
believe that this period in American
history is over or very nearly over and
I can talk about open water bottle
someone's uh someone's planning to
poison me I think probably the
Department of Homeland Security which
I'll tell you what I really really want
that's one of the first acts of the next
president just to change the name of
that department
we should not it does saat it does
really sound like a literal translation
of hi my sticker height applied to him
doesn't it anyway okay all right so how
do I do give you a really quick
explanation of why I think everything is
is changing now partly there really well
there really is a shift in public
opinion broadly if you look at variety
of polls they show that if you like
economic populism has made it come back
if you look at various kinds of attempts
to aggregate data on people's views on
economic issues the public is more
liberal now than it has been since the
early 1960s there's a recent it's not in
the book as it's more reason than that
it's just a recent poll by democracy
core they look at their starting point
is a huge huge fraction of the country
of the public believes that the country
is heading in the wrong direction and
then they ask people who said the
country's heading the wrong direction to
choose from a variety of phrases to what
what they care about most I would have
thought that Iraq and would be at the
top but actually the top two were big
businesses get whatever they want in
Washington and leaders have forgotten
the middle class so I think there is a
real a real swing and people and people
have noticed the extraordinary increase
in inequality that's taken place in this
country and and they're not happy about
it but what about the ability to wield
does weapons of mass distraction and I
really have a pretty simple answer to
that which is macaca
I thought that moment the the defeat of
George Allen was in in Virginia Senate
race was extraordinary not because
George Allen but we have to really have
read some of the articles you know
national review a few months before the
incident about George Allen to get a
sense he was viewed as you know the
second coming of Ronald Reagan he was
viewed as the man who was going to a
future Republican presidential nominee
almost for sure and and then he was
being trailed on the campaign as all
candidates are now by somebody from the
other side with a videocam and in this
case a young American man of South Asian
descent and he used what turned out to
be an obscure racial insult repeatedly
against the guy well that's not new I
mean racial insults are certainly
nothing new in American politics what's
new is that the the public wouldn't
stand for it the voters of Virginia
wouldn't stand for it
and there's a whole array of reasons to
whole array of reasons why race which
has been against central to the American
political story is just losing its
effectiveness part of it is just the the
raw demography we are becoming a more
diverse or to be a little bit blunt or
less white country the growing role of
Latinos and of to a lesser extent of
Asians is shifting the demographic mix
these are groups that are they non-white
well the Republican base sees them as
non-white which is what matters and they
respond by actually voting heavily
against the Republican Party as it now
stands in a way that's why the fact that
SJ Sidharth was aka macaca was there was
also partly revealing it was in fact a
child of immigrants that that was the
subject of the insults the other which
is more uplifting is that we really are
a less racist country not entirely if
obviously by a longshot but much more so
so you look at some of the
I in in Constable liberal I I i find it
revealing to look at polls not on direct
political issues but on more sort of
emotional issues that really get at some
sense of how people feel so in 1978 just
on the birds of the great triumph of
movement conservatism a solid majority
of americans did not think that
interracial marriage was acceptable
rights week i don't know what that was
about but it's all in anyways the solid
majority of americans in the in the in
the late nineteen seventies opposed
interracial marriage today seventy seven
percent say it's perfectly okay we just
have changed we're not we're not that
country anymore
which means that the prime issue that
the right has used to win elections is
no longer really available to them and
in fact can turn into a liability as it
did for george allen so i think that the
time is ripe for a huge change in
direction for a a progressive movement
if you like to to undo then you had the
damage from the conservative movement
where does it start and the answer of
course is health care health care is so
it's so first of all just in itself it's
something where the need for reform the
growing sense of crisis is overwhelming
and the US health care system has well
the US health care system is one of the
wonders of the world i guess you might
say it manages to be both monstrously
unjust and monstrously inefficient we're
the only advanced country who in which
citizens can be denied essential health
care because they can't afford it with
the only advanced country in which
citizens can be financially ruined by
the costs of essential health care and
yet we spend far far more on health care
per person than any other country
without better results and in in many
cases with worth with worst results our
life expectancy is still I believe
slightly higher than that of Costa Rica
but we really do very very badly
on on the metrics we achieve no better
health care maybe worse at an enormous
expense and we know how to fix it there
are ideally I'd be for a Medicare type
system for everyone there are reasons
why politically that's difficult to move
to at least as a first step we have
pretty good compromises coming pretty
good hybrid systems with prospects for
improvement coming out now from the
Democratic presidential candidates
I had to see sometimes I have to pinch
myself because not much more than two
and a half years ago it really seemed
possible that Bush was going to gut
social security the centerpiece of the
New Deal now it looks like we have a
reasonable possibility of actually
having legislate legislation
establishing a universal health care
system by 2010 so it's really amazing
none of this is guaranteed and I spent a
lot of time you might say wallowing in
the history of the New Deal because
Franklin Delano Roosevelt is my hero a
lot of these things and clearly had an
opportunity the the Great Depression had
discredited the right-wing orthodoxy of
his time he was able to say there's this
great speech by at Madison Square Garden
before the 36 election where he was able
to say that we have always known that
the heedless pursuit of self-interest
was bad morals we now know that it is
bad economics too so I but you look and
you realize it it might not have
happened if it had been someone else
some of the other candidates who might
have gotten that Democratic nomination
in 32 were pretty much Orthodox would
not have have done the things he did I
do harken back a little bit to the
Gilded Age when there were populist
Democrats but they never got they were
so underfunded when they ran they never
got anywhere near the White House the
only Democrat who did win was Grover
Cleveland who was what they called at
the time a borbón Democrat as in the
French royal family so it was was he
they and they were you know not so
different from the Republicans
and and that is the real question I
think right now the the odds are that it
will be a Democrat in the White House
next next year that we will have that
there will be a Democratic majority in
Congress and that the Democratic
majority in the house is actually the
most progressive Democratic majority
ever in terms of its positioning but we
don't know what they'll actually deliver
the question I asked in The Times a few
weeks back was you know we hope that
we're about to elect another FDR we're
afraid that we might be about to elect
another Grover Cleveland and that's and
I have friends who think that Hillary
Clinton looks a lot like Grover
Cleveland but I'd have to say the
policies espousing right now are in fact
very very progressive so hopeful but
anxious I'll just close by saying you
know the change since I think I was at
this book fair or four years ago with
the great unraveling and that was a book
written at a time when things seemed
incredibly dark for me I think for a lot
of people it felt like a nightmare you
know one of those nightmares where
you're screaming and no one can hear you
which is particularly odd when you do
you're doing your screaming on the op-ed
page of the New York Times
it is so much better now the atmosphere
is so much better that I'm feeling you
know incredibly hopeful and optimistic
some of my friends are at say I'm
sounding so optimistic they're worried
and they want to know whether I'm
actually okay but I think the prospects
for change are better than they have
been for a very very long time so I'm
hopeful and I'm hopeful that this book
will you know be marked like the
conscience of conservative was as the
beginning of a great change but this
time for the better in American life
thank you
I was going to say the questioners
should line up behind the microphone but
they're half a dozen there already so I
suspect mr. Krugman will need to answer
however he also needs a drink of water
so while you continue to queue up okay
we're ready for the first question okay
AARP which totally capitulated on
Medicare Part T if you years ago
is promoting a campaign called divided
we fail the ideas that we seniors should
urge our legislators Republicans and
Democrats to work together on our behalf
this button which depicts half an
elephant and half a donkey yeah is what
they're giving out I consider it
half-assed I'm also wearing it upside
down as a sign of the universal sign of
distress
would you care to comment on the idea of
Republicans working together with
Democrats on anything okay in fact
there's a in the last chapter of
conscience of the liberal I talked about
partisanship and why sometimes it's a
good thing there are times when you know
there's a beltway illusion pundits
inside the beltway think that the the
American Center is you know somewhere
between Joe Lieberman and John McCain
this is not true right if you look at
American public opinion it is strongly
progressive it is not at all if anything
it's a little bit to the left of the
center of the Democratic Party so and
the idea that we're going to get
compromised again FDR that same speech
Madison Square Garden speech he talked
about the hatred he engendered among you
know the the the forces of opposed to
and then and he said I welcome their
hatred it was a he was a staunch
partisan the great year of
bipartisanship in American life began
after the 1948 election when Harry
Truman
everybody knows given how Harry but who
was he giving hell and what was
than hell about he was giving the
Republicans held for wanting to roll
back the New Deal and after the
Republican Party realized for a while
that they could not do that
Dwight Eisenhower wrote a letter to his
brother about people who thought they
could do away with Social Security and
and he said they their number is
negligible and they are stupid
the only after the the basically the the
decision of Republicans to accept these
institutions was there an era
bipartisanship and that's what has to
happen this time there has to be
universal health care is not going to
have Republican support it's going to be
passed if it happens at all it's going
to be passed over kicking and screaming
you know think about the fact that the
Bush administration is violently opposed
to expanding health care for children
let alone to the country as a whole
once it's in place and maybe after the
people who opposed it have lost a couple
of national elections very badly then we
can possibly get to a new era of
bipartisanship you can see this now in
California where Arnold Schwarzenegger
who you know I think Schwarzenegger is
actually the the future of the
Republican Party as in style although he
won't ever be president except on The
Simpsons but he after he was rocked back
by this California voters on his on his
propositions that then he decided he
really acted govern as a centrist from
California point of view which is
actually quite liberal that's where
it'll go but first no the idea that
we're going to get the the party of
Grover Norquist and Tom DeLay to work
together with with others on on solving
our problems of healthcare is it's not
going to happen
I'm totally surprised at your answer my
question my question involves the
difficulty of possibly admitting you're
wrong in a politically a contentious
environment I think of a column you
wrote a couple of years ago on Iraq
likening the administration's position
to playing a poker game they were losing
the hand and rather than cut their
losses I think that's what you said they
wanted to keep playing because you don't
want to admit you're wrong I'm a skeptic
on Iraq I look at the surge violence is
down I don't think it's working maybe in
a year it will allow the dysfunctional
government to work it's one thing for me
to have those thoughts somebody is
public as you if you voice doubts that
would be vilified how do you deal with
that oh I I mean I like to hope that I'm
willing to admit mistakes when I make
them and I have but not about that I
think if we look at Iraq I don't know
the Latin but they have made a desert
and they called it peace violence is
down in Baghdad basically cuz sectarian
cleansing is nearly complete
violence is down in Anbar province
because we've not because we defeated
the insurgents but basically because
they won and we decided to accept them
and they got rid of the troubles and
outsiders but effectively the people
that we are now working with in Anbar
are the insurgents violence is somewhat
down in southern Iraq basically because
we've reached an accommodation with the
Shiite militias so no it's it's not and
the public you know this is this war is
still costing nearly 10 billion dollars
a month so you may say well you know the
the the number of Americans killed per
month is down to the levels of 2005 but
you know we didn't think it was actually
going well in 2005 so no this is not
this is not the success story in the end
you know we may get a somewhat stable
Shiite acqua see in Iraq is that was
that what we were prepared to spend two
trillion dollars for
I think I'm as skeptical as you I think
I meant the question in a more general
sense people don't I try to admit
mistakes when I make them I'd like to
hope that we'll see more of that the the
most disturbing thing I might say about
Rudy Giuliani and of course there are
many disturbing things is that but he
shows sign of being even less able to
admit error than than the current
occupant of the White House I want to
get back into your point of economics
that you opened up I really am sorry
about this this is what book tour does
to you thank you to two aspects of the
of the economic situation of one which
is rarely talked about except in a
partisan way but nothing is done about
it and that is the impact of the women
at entering into the economic society if
you will the breaking or at least the
cracking of the glass ceiling I think
that business has taken advantage of
women trying to get into the society by
still keeping a tremendous disparity in
the income okay and at the at the same
time creating the same is a question no
excuse me
so at the same income I wanted to come
at them the creating the same income for
the family that existed before the entry
of the woman all right yeah no I I think
I can look that there has been the
transformation with increased
participation of women in the workforce
they still earn less than men even with
everything taking equivalence although
that is somewhat diminished it's not a
major factor in explaining the the
inequality you can just I could go
through that chapter in verse but it's
not it is it is true that if you look at
me and family income it's up entirely
its are not up very much and it's up to
the extent
that it's up its up entirely because of
an increased number of working wives so
you know primase working males or
actually making less than they did 35
years ago but this is not there are many
put it this way France you look at
people of prime working years 25 to 54
the fraction of French people who are
employed is exactly the same as the
fraction of American people were
employed it's 80% in both countries and
in both countries
there's large-scale participation by
women in the workforce yet they don't
have our increase in inequality because
it's not it's not that the I think other
people would like to ask question the
the please please hello professor group
I'm sorry they're just a lot of people
here and and and we have very little
time that's okay my question is about
the US dollar which affects everybody in
this room it's uh has lost value over
the last five years something like close
to thirty five percent which means if
you take one hundred dollars out of the
bank
you can throw thirty five of them away
and that's pretty much what's happened
to your wallet my question to you is do
you see this as a good or a bad thing
for the US economy and what you see is
the most likely a catalyst to turn this
around in the future if you think there
is one okay uh yeah do I see the fall in
the US dollar as a good or a bad thing
for the US economy and the answer of
course is yes
look it does being somewhat higher
inflation higher prices for imported
goods means a lot higher prices if you
were planning to go to Europe this
summer which I am the but actually it's
one of the saving graces of the economy
right now housing is collapsing subprime
you know we have a everything domestic
is in big big trouble and the one bright
spot in the economy is rising exports
and the falling dollar is is actually
helping that and I think it's it's it's
largely unavoidable the US has to the US
trade deficit has to come down the only
way that can happen
is by making us woods more attractive
both to domestic purchasers and to
foreign purchasers and that means a
weaker dollar I actually have a blog at
the Times now and I have a post I put up
last night with the slightly alarming
title to me of Robert Rubin is wrong
about the dollar very hard to actually
say Robert Rubin is wrong but but I did
and I don't think that the phone of the
dollar is avoidable it's just something
that is actually required as part of the
process of adjustment the dollar was
grossly overvalued on a PPE basis which
is proof of the pudding is in the eating
we just were not selling enough stuff
over abroad and that just requires a
weaker dollar historians have come to
compare the u.s. with the Roman Empire
we know that the Roman Empire sail the
Mediterranean for a thousand years about
being a challenge do you see any threat
global threat to the middle class
through free trade or is it a unfair
comparison oh yeah I don't think we're I
don't think comparisons between us and
the Roman Empire are are very accurate I
mean the the Romans actually you know
the Romans actually managed to win their
Wars of occupation the
no it's just very very different United
States does not the United States
doesn't depend on tribute for its
prosperity no we're not we're not likely
we're not that kind of society and
actually you know conquest conquest
doesn't pay in the modern world the the
most prosperous economies tend to be the
ones that that where the countries
managed to mostly mind their own
business
so no I don't think there are a lot of
things that scare me I mean beyond the
immediate financial worries you know I
worry a lot about the environment there
is this question though in the end I
don't worry about China as a competitor
I do worry that the Chinese are gonna
poison us all but by burning so much
coal both both through both through
carbon dioxide emissions and through all
the mercury they're putting into the
global atmosphere but that's those are
the things that worry me not not these
sort of rise and full of empire we are
we are not an empire both in terms of
motivations and in terms of competence
we just don't stack up against the
Romans thank you very much for your
willingness to come out and visit and
address this crowd this morning and
everyone appreciates it well thank you
you touched on the American dollars
declined to 76 cents that close on
Friday
can you speak a moment about housing
administration or the one trillion
dollars which is estimated to be either
reset or foreclosed on and the best
estimates are there's 50 billion a year
over the next five years a falling
dollar means less value of art assets
I'm sorry we're talking about a rock
that's all we're talking about you
mentioned that we have a falling dollar
yeah and does that not mean that the
hard assets held by Americans are going
to decline because they were bought with
that dollar
no no because the dollar is falling in
terms of other people's currencies this
affects Americans only to the extent
that you're going to be buying something
that
valued in someone else's currency which
means some imported goods
it means certainly if you're planning to
travel abroad but it doesn't no it
doesn't the most most of what we buy is
is services produced here it's just not
not an issue and in fact maybe I should
give you the the reassuring why we are
not Argentina the the trouble the places
where a falling currency produces a
terrible crisis are places that have a
lot of foreign debt in someone else's
currency so when the currency devalues
the value of that far in debt blows up
and value we don't have that problem our
foreign debts are in dollars the United
States actually has a lot of foreign
assets to which are in euros or yen or
and and those actually increase in value
so we're actually are our balance sheets
get better when the dollar falls so it's
not there are a lot of things to worry
about but not that one it's I know
people get really upset but really your
ability to buy our house is not going to
be affected by the falling dollar your
ability to buy most things is not going
to be affected your ability to buy a
house in London is going to be affected
but you can't afford it in any way my
concern is a question I've asked other
people but my concern is as the
president and Cheney have been working
on a unitary executive with the Military
Commission an executive directive number
51 do we see any possible problems in
the next election especially with the
Iran thing elephant as an excuse for
anything
well Iran scares me you know all serious
analyses say that bombing would be a
terrible stupid mistake which means it
might well happen
the
if Bush had been more successful I would
worry a lot about what
extra-constitutional things you might do
I don't think many people would go along
with with something at this point I mean
it's a peculiar way that's almost a
saving grace of this administration that
they've been so happiest at doing
anything except except waving the flag
and and and and scaring people that
nobody really puts much trust in what
they would do so I'm not too worried but
you know it is true I mean I can't
really answer your question but it is
true that that for the most part worst
expectations have been feel fulfilled
again and again these past seven years
but I guess I I don't
that we will have a not entirely fair
but not grossly distorted election next
year I hope I'm right and and if it's
held that way I don't believe that I
don't believe that this gang will be in
power anymore
one final question please as the dollar
continues to fall does this not mean
that the price of imported oil will
increase and will that not have a
recessionary effect on the US economy
yeah quite I mean the price of oil is
certainly it is now back inflation
adjusted to its levels right after the
the fall of the Shah in Iran this is
this is not good we do burn less oil per
dollar of GDP than we used to it's not
quite as exposed but yeah I mean all
right my record at calling recessions is
not good although let me tell you
there's a dirty little secret
nobody's is but the people who try to do
this I'm not even trying with people who
are trying to do this are now giving us
about 50/50 odds on a recession next
year and and even if it isn't recession
it can feel pretty lousy
I think we're guaranteed of a 2008 that
feels really lousy weak employment
growth so sure I mean oil prices plus
housing and that when I did chlorite
plus the the financial spillover from
housing this is even in economic terms
the Bush administration is going to go
out with an ich it's pretty bad
whether it's you know I don't think it's
the end of the world but it is it is
certainly looking like a pretty grim
next year trying to think of something
hopeful well these things do go away
eventually
someday maybe okay thank you all